please say good afternoon to seg after
National president Fran Drescher also
chair of the negotiating committee and
Dr Crabtree Ireland
good afternoon good afternoon everybody
I'm Duncan Crabtree Ireland national
executive director and chief negotiator
for saigatra
yesterday our Union celebrated the 90th
anniversary of the incorporation of
Screen Actors Guild during our nearly
century-long existence we've fought for
and achieved countless gains for working
actors
today we embark on a new important
chapter in our Union's history earlier
this morning the sagafter national board
convened following four weeks of
negotiations with the alliance of motion
picture and television producers the
ampte
because the amptp remains unwilling to
offer a fair deal on key issues
essential to protecting the livelihoods
of working actors and performers sag
after his national board unanimously
voted to issue a strike order against
the studios and streamers
from the time negotiations began on June
7th sag after staff and the members of
our negotiating committee have worked
overtime devoting their evenings
weekends and holidays to achieving a
deal that would ensure a sustainable
future for the acting profession but
despite our team's efforts the nptp has
remained steadfast in its commitment to
devaluing the work of our members
actors deserve a contract that reflects
the changes that have taken place in the
industry unfortunately the current
streaming model has undercut performers
residual income and high inflation has
further reduced our members ability to
make ends meet additionally industry
expectations around soft tape auditions
mean performers are bearing casting
costs that were once the responsibility
of producers
to complicate matters further actors now
face an existential threat to their
livelihoods with the rise of generative
AI technology we've proposed contract
changes that address these issues but
the amptp has been uninterested in our
proposals because of this the board has
determined that union members should
withhold their labor until a fair
contract can be achieved a strike is an
instrument of Last Resort we've tried
for four weeks to reach a deal with the
amdtp and unfortunately they have left
us with no alternative
although we're all disappointed with the
ampcp's reluctance
to cooperate the solidarity amongst our
members has never been stronger based on
the enthusiasm I'm seeing from everyone
I truly believe this Union has the unity
and the resolve needed to fight for the
future of their careers due to the broad
nature of our membership this strike
does not affect all members of all
contract areas just those working under
the 2020 TV theatrical contract
performers working in interactive
entertainment audiobooks music
commercials and other contract areas
will not be directly impacted
the strike will begin at midnight
tonight and all of us union members
leadership and staff will be out on the
picket lines tomorrow morning
members are urged to go to
sagafterstrike.org for answers to common
questions as well as information on
picket locations I'd now like to turn
the microphone over to Sag after
president Fran Drescher thank you thank
you Duncan and thank you everybody for
coming to this press conference today
it's really important that this
negotiation be covered because the eyes
of the world and particularly the eyes
of Labor
are upon us what happens here is
important because what's happening to us
is happening across all fields of Labor
by means of when employers make
Wall Street and greed their priority and
they forget about the essential
contributors that make the machine run
we have a problem
and we are experiencing that right at
this moment this is a very seminal hour
for us
I went in in earnest
thinking that we would be able to avert
a strike
the gravity of this move is not lost on
me or our negotiating committee or our
board members who have voted unanimously
to proceed with a strike
it's a very serious thing that impacts
thousands if not millions of people all
across this country and around the world
not only members of this Union but
people who work in other industries that
service the people that work in this
industry
and so it came with great sadness that
we came to this Crossroads but we had no
choice
we are the victims here
we are being
victimized by a very greedy entity
I am shocked by the way the people that
we have been in business with are
treating us I cannot believe it quite
frankly
how far apart we are on so many things
how they plead poverty that they're
losing money left and right when giving
hundreds of millions of dollars to their
CEOs
it is disgusting shame on them they
stand on the wrong side of history at
this very moment
we stand in solidarity
in unprecedented Unity
our Union and our sister unions and the
unions around the world
are standing by us
as well as other labor unions
because at some point The Jig Is up you
cannot keep being dwindled and
marginalized and disrespected and
Dishonored
the entire business model has been
changed
by streaming digital AI
this is a moment of history that is a
moment of truth
if we don't stand tall right now
we are all going to be in trouble we are
all going to be in Jeopardy of being
replaced by machines
and big business who cares more about
Wall Street than you and your family
most of Americans don't have more than
500 dollars
in a in an emergency this is a very big
deal and it weighed heavy on us
but at some point you have to say no
we're not going to take this anymore you
people are crazy what are you doing why
are you doing this
primatically they all say we're the
center of the wheel everybody else
Tinkers around our Artistry but actions
speak louder than words
and there was nothing there it was
insulting
so we came together in strength and
solidarity and unity with the largest
strike authorization vote in our Union's
history
and we made the hard decision
that we tell you as we stand before you
today
this is Major it's really serious and
it's going to impact every single person
that is in labor
we are fortunate enough to be in a
country right now that happens to be
labor friendly
and yet we were facing opposition that
was so labor unfriendly so tone deaf
to what we are saying
cannot change the business model
as much as it has changed and not expect
the contract to change too
we're not going to keep doing
incremental changes on a contract that's
no longer honors what is happening right
now with this business model that was
foisted upon us
what are we doing moving around
furniture on the Titanic
it's crazy
so The Jig Is up amptp We Stand Tall you
have to wake up and smell the coffee
we are labor and we stand tall and we
demand respect
and to be honored for our contribution
you share the wealth because you cannot
exist without us
thank you
[Applause]
so
that's our president
um questions
uh right here Jeremy
contract
another key issue
so first of all I think it's important
for us to know that we respect every
Union's right to negotiate the contract
that's right for their members and
there's nothing about our statements
about not wanting to be held to pattern
bargaining that in any way are intended
to detract from the dgas agreement or
any other Union's agreement but sagafter
members are sagatha members and we went
into that negotiation negotiating for
our members and the fact of the matter
is that yes the amptp wants to insist
that other unions adhere to things that
they've negotiated with with other
unions and in the case of for example
minimum increases that's one where
that's the case the companies insisted
that we agree to limit the increases in
minimum salaries for our members to a
pattern
pattern negotiating committee rejected
that idea I reject that idea our members
need to receive increases that allow
them to keep up with the pace of
inflation we believe that our members
should not be working in 2023 for less
money in real dollars than they made in
2020 and we certainly believe that our
members should not be working at the end
of the term of this contract in 2026 for
less money than they made in real
dollars in 2020. that's wrong it's
unfair and it's unacceptable and so we
attending agreement on that
on that point hang on one second please
advice
all right guys let's go ahead and stop
it yeah Pam can we ask the question now
yeah you sure can okay Duncan and Fran
so that so the amptv just sent out a
press release basically saying you guys
are reiterating what they said yesterday
and what Bob Iger said you guys have
chosen a path that will lead to
financial hardship for countless
thousands of people depend on the
industry they're claiming they offered a
60 a 76 inch percent increase in high
budget svod foreign residuals 58
increase in salaries for major roles
they'd say 11 11 pay increase in year
one blah blah they're saying they're
claiming all these double-digit promises
and they're claiming they had a
groundbreaking I'm quoting them AI
proposal which protects performers
digital likeness so what do you say to
that well let me Fran may have some
things you want to say that but let me
let me just take one of the items that
you mentioned and I'm not going to be
able not having seen their press release
I can't respond to every point of it but
this groundbreaking AI proposal that
they gave us yesterday and that
groundbreaking AI proposal they proposed
that our background performers should be
able to be scanned get paid for one
day's pay and their company should own
that scan their image their likeness and
to be able to use it for the rest of
Eternity in any project they want with
no consent and no compensation so if you
think that's a groundbreaking proposal I
suggest you think again
uh
a few weeks ago uh you guys put out a
video that suggested that you were
seeing progress in the in the talks and
you sounded uh encouraged by what was
happening so what turned what was the
pivot where did things go south
well you know initially we started kind
of on the outside
they weren't really ready to get to the
core issues and we're encouraged quite
frankly but we didn't realize that that
was where it ended where it began and
ended and all the core ingredients you
know we were basically either
stonewalled or we're so far apart that
you know it was just
and in Earnest we gave them an extension
of 12 days which they absolutely wasted
making us feel like we've been duped
like maybe it was just to let Studios
promote their summer movies another 12
days they stayed locked behind closed
doors they continued to cancel our
meetings with them
we thought you know well maybe they're
really getting into it but then what we
ultimately received from them was what
my mom would call a legend of schmeck
was this in fact historic
can you repeat that again yeah the
motion picture companies released a
statement saying that that the union
walked away from a historic offer that
you guys left the negotiating table was
this in fact historic what was historic
about it is that we were
really so
marginalized so Dishonored and so
respect and disrespected that it was
really egregious
and disgusting so that's what was his
story that at a moment when
um streaming and Ai and digital is so
prevalent in the industry it is
disemboweled
the industry that we once knew when I do
did The Nanny and everybody was part of
the gravy train now it's a walled in
vacuum
and not only is it unfair to everybody
up and down the ladder but the entity
that employs us
it's really Un-American and it's
unconscionable what are you doing we're
not curing cancer here it's a collective
art form
we have a live stream this is being
viewed by several thousand people online
so I need you guys to use the
microphones we're going to go back to me
recognizing you and you will go to a
microphone either here or here Gene
you talk a little bit about how long you
expect this to go on are we talking
about weeks are we talking about months
and what would it take to get back to
the table that's up to them we're open
to talking to them tonight
but uh you know it's it's up to all of
this
is because of their behavior it's up to
them if they're willing to talk in a
normal way that honors what we do
I mean they are they are well aware of
what it takes to make a deal Fran and I
personally spoke to several of the CEOs
of these Studios yesterday uh and at
length they know what it will take to
make a deal they have the power in their
hands to make a deal and avoid the
strike they chose not to do that and
last night we told the A and PTP
directly across the table we're ready
willing and able to return to the
negotiating table whenever they're ready
to do so their response to us was that
they would be ready to talk whenever we
would act in a civilized manner not be
on strike we told them that it's not
uncivilized for people to go on strike
it's a moral right it's a human right
and it's a legal right of our members to
collectively bargain to organize and to
go on strike if needed to defend their
rights and that we will be happy to
approach them and negotiate with them
whenever they're ready to do so we were
then later informed that it would
probably be a while so we will be here
doing what we need to do to defend our
members and to ensure we get a fair
contract and we encourage them to come
back to the table because we're ready to
talk with ever they are
they are all right right here please
it's obvious that amdtv is uh working in
a coordinated effort with all the
studios are you planning to do the same
the same with the other entertainment
unions we've been in constant contact
with our sister unions you know the the
other use in this industry have been
incredibly supportive we have been
incredibly supportive of them I'm sure
it hasn't gone unnoticed that thousands
of sagafter members have been walking
the wga picket line since the beginning
of May but you know over the past years
we've been working together closely the
relationships between the industry
entertainment industry units have never
been tighter have never been closer and
we absolutely are standing in solidarity
with them and they are standing in
solidarity with us
all right we're going to go to Abby with
people
to the mines please hi um a lot of us
are wondering how this is going to
affect a promotion of past work uh not
current movies to be promoted by actors
but things like participating in a panel
at 90s con or if they are being
recognized for their entire body of work
can you clarify a little bit about the
terms
sure we will be issuing a strike notice
in order to our members today that lay
out exactly what members are prohibited
from doing as part of the strike and
what they can do we've also communicated
directly with members agents lawyers and
publicists so that they have this
information as well in general terms any
kind of promotion of any project that
was made under the TV theatrical
agreements either current or past will
not be allowed whether that's added con
at a festival at a panel on social media
at a Premiere in any form members who
have you know other types of activities
going on like autograph signings or
things that are not related to specific
companies or projects that are produced
under the disagreements they'll be able
to continue doing that but we encourage
all members who have any doubt about the
boundaries there to reach out to the
union read the guidance that we'll give
them and we can answer their questions
directly and individually
all right over here hey guys what do you
make of the reports that the amp uh the
Academy's strategy was to lead union
members dry I know those in specific
regards to the wga but what were your
thoughts on that that piece that came
out
it was supported in the press that it
was supporting the Press just recently
that there were some Executives from the
studios who stated that uh you know that
it was okay for writers to go homeless
as a result of this strike where that
like you said that they want to leave
the people dry I mean I think Fran might
have something necessary evil necessary
evil that's right
I mean we had a white board with quotes
just so the room would remember
some of the things that were said but
you know what eventually the people
break down the gates of Versailles and
then it's over well we're at that moment
right now
thank you right here
All Right Touch on KMBC uh as you know
this is going to have a significant
impact on the LA economy uh perhaps
costing it as much as 30 million dollars
a day what would you want to say to the
businesses to the people who are going
to be losing their living because of
Hollywood who are going to be suffering
alongside with you
well ah believe me our heart beliefs
that we had to make this decision
but we can't not get what these members
deserve
because it's only going to get worse
this is where we drew the Line in the
Sand and it's a terrible thing to have
to do but we were forced into it
and let's not let's not forget actors
are working people too alongside
everyone else in this economy and every
working person should feel empowered to
stand up for themselves and when an
employer especially these big
multinational corporations wants to take
advantage of you wants to use their
power to squash you under their heel it
is your right and your obligation to
stand up to them and I have a very
strong feeling that those other people
whether they're parts of unions yet or
not will see what our members are doing
and we'll understand why we had to do it
and Fran and Duncan I have a quick
question Leslie the Associated Press
um how do you anticipate that this will
affect Amy's campaigning amongst actress
since nominations were just announced
yesterday
the uh the our arm strike rules will not
allow any form of promotion for
television series uh streaming series
that have been produced under these
contracts my expectation is that it will
bring any actor participation in any
campaigning to a close
hi
um Charlie trepany with USA Today
um you mentioned uh some of the issues
that went into this decision to go on a
strike involving salary and generated AI
was there one particular overriding
issue that proved to be the biggest deal
breaker for the Union
I think there are several really
important issues Fran and I talked to
the CEOs about those issues yesterday
and we've mentioned a couple of them AI
of course is really important but in
addition to that the basic respect
reflected in minimums that keep you at
least so that you're not earning less
money today than you were earning years
ago that's another example and also as
Fran has talked about the fact that this
business model has been changed but the
companies want to just keep our members
locked in a contract that that doesn't
reflect that change we have a proposal
regarding the sharing of revenue from
streaming services that has been on the
table since day one of negotiations the
companies have refused to engage on that
proposal and give it any meaningful
discussion much less agreed to it and we
discussed that issue with the CEOs
yesterday as well
broadcast is that we are here at this
press conference I would like to ask you
in Spanish
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
very much
you know a friend and Duncan you both
cast as as I wanted to step back as
existential and that makes the stakes
very high and of course the companies
claim it's existential for them in terms
of the challenges that the business is
facing economically and Theatrical and
linear television the amount of money
they needed to spend to compete with
Netflix and streaming how do you
how do you win a victory uh in a
situation where there's just so much
head-to-head so much fear uncertainty
about and so much at stake
I just say that I had zero doubt that
these companies could have agreed to
every single item in our proposal
package without a problem whatsoever in
their bottom line they could do that
they choose not to do that we told them
we told the CEOs yesterday and we told
the ampcp across the table as it relates
to our streaming Revenue share proposal
that we would be flexible on the terms
of that the issue is that there has to
be a change in the structure it's like
what Fran said we can't continue working
off of a contract that was designed for
a different business model despite that
indication of flexibility unwillingness
to move in our direction or even
substantly discuss proposals there is no
this strike could have been avoided a
hundred percent by these companies
simply being reasonable and nothing
about this contract
this is a matter of respect for members
for the work they contribute and it just
it just isn't there
uh do what well yeah
I you know I mean I said to the faces
that you know you're sitting there
trying to squeeze us out of our
likelihood you're systematically
figuring out ways to carve us out of
what is due us
and you're sitting on the wrong side of
History shame on you that's what I have
to say
Alison petrovski Channel 9 Australia
friend you mentioned that the eyes of
the world are watching at the moment
what is your message to actors and other
members of the entertainment industry
operating a indifferent part of the
world that operating in different parts
of the world but fighting the same
battles that you are here
well I you know we all have to stand
together on this because it's like a
malignancy that's spreading and we're
already in stage four
and if it doesn't get attended to
immediately at swiftland with precision
it's going to destroy not only each of
us
but the industry at Large
I'll just add you know sag after has
members all around the world and we also
have extremely close relationships with
our sibling actor unions all around the
world as well and there have been plenty
of times in the past when tag after
members have gone to bat to fight for
our fellow members around the world
whether it be in New Zealand with
respect to The Hobbit situation whether
it be in South Africa helping our
colleagues there achieve copyright
Protections in their domestic law that
they didn't have before we've stood by
and we do stand by them and we know that
they stand by us we've spoken to them
and we know that we have solidarity from
actors all around the world because they
know this is a Justified this is the
same fight that they have we're all in
it together and we are going to win it
hi Brooks
you know there's been a lot of
Optics of CEOs that can and
the companies pushed back by sending
photo of you in Italy and
that wasn't a selfie excuse me I just
want to set the record straight up
before you do you want to say something
before Sammy answers that before fan
answers that I want to say it is
outrageous that they would do that you
know what Fran was doing was Fran was
working which is what our members do and
for these employers to cynically try to
turn our members against Fran because
she's doing a job that she was under
contract to do while by the way she was
zooming into our negotiations after work
hours working 18 hours or more a day it
is outrageous it is wrong it's
despicable and they should be ashamed of
it but I'm sorry Fran if you want to say
that
no I appreciate that I mean uh you know
I'm a brand ambassador for a fashion
company and so is Kim I had only met Kim
seconds before that publicity picture
was taken
it had nothing to do with being at a
party or having fun it was absolute work
I was inherent makeup three hours a day
walking in heels on cobblestones doing
things like that which is work not fun
I'm sure Kim would have rather been at
her home in Malibu with her children too
but we work that's what we do and at 10
30 at night I would leave the event I
would go to my hotel room and I'd call
into the zoom and when I couldn't get
through to them because I was on a plane
I was texting with them constantly
throughout the plane ride I worked
Around the Clock in three different time
zones because my parents live in Florida
though I keep asking them to move here
and I manage their well-being as well so
you know I think that all of the people
standing behind me stand behind me
[Applause]
um
you said there was a proposal regarding
streaming
they did not engage with I just wanted
to just talk a little bit more about
what some of the terms were as
particularly involving viewership data
sure man I hesitate to get too much into
the weeds but the concept of this
proposal which was actually inspired by
Fran was that we would uh we would
receive a percentage of streaming
subscription revenue and that streaming
subscription Revenue would be divided up
um by Project based on the Project's
contribution to the success of that
streaming service now as I'm sure many
of you who follow the industry know the
streamers are famous for not sharing
information being non-transparent and
since we knew that they wouldn't want to
share any kind of viewership success
data we went and found another source
for that data from a particular company
in the industry and analytics company
and then instead of engaging with the
proposal discussing it with us making
any counter proposal trying to figure
out if there was a way to get to
agreement what they did is launch a uh
you know a uh an attack on that company
trying to claim that that company
doesn't have
quality or whatever else again not
legitimate at all this was their
distraction tactic to try to avoid
engaging on a totally legitimate
proposal and from day one to day 35 of
these negotiations we never got any
substantive response to that proposal
and it's just part of the larger story
of the companies refusing to engage with
legitimate proposals and refusing to do
what it takes to try and make a deal and
that's the reality
thank you right here
Hello Alex golden of NHK Japan
broadcasting uh if I have it right this
is the first sack after striking decades
since the 1960 or 1986 it's the 14 hours
my question is do you remember what the
issues in those previous strikes were
and do they relate to today at all
so first of all let me just say this is
the first I got the strike in this
contract uh in over 40 years it is true
we have had other strikes since that
time in other contracts but you know
this is not a strike happy Union this is
a union that views strikes as a last
resort but we're not afraid to do them
when that's what it takes to make sure
our members receive their Fair contract
you know our strike in 1960 is the
reason that our members have a health
plan it's the reason that our members
have a pension plan and it's the reason
why our members get residuals uh you
know and and successive strikes since
then have been the way that we have
achieved key proposals that have been
necessary to keep our members uh you
know having a professional life having a
career and having the ability to do this
job I'm not an actor but I know because
I spend all my time around actors it is
a hard job anyone who doesn't know that
it is a job that requires you to have
incredible resilience that requires you
to spend most of your time looking for
work as opposed to doing work it is a
job that it makes it hard to get basics
in life like health insurance like of
any kind of retirement that's what this
Union provides and I highly doubt there
are any members of this union today who
would say it wasn't worth it to go on
strike in 1960 for as long as it took to
achieve Health Plan in our residuals
well this is the same kind of strike
this is the kind of strike that makes
sure that our members livelihoods are
not taken away by artificial
intelligence this is the kind of strike
that makes sure is this industry changes
its business model our members are not
left behind this is the kind of strike
that says our members are not going to
take less money six years later because
of inflation that the companies refuse
to account for and a host of other
things and it's the kind of strike that
is is fortunate it's sad that we're at
this point but it's a hundred percent
necessary and it's 100 deserved by the
actions of these companies okay last
question right here right here hi so
let's finish it up with what is your
message to the fans and consumers who
aren't interested in the Nuance that
we're discussing here today they just
want their favorite TV shows or they
want to go to the movies
well what makes you think they're not
interested in What's Happening Here I
think that they have an allegiance to
all of us because they we bring joy to
their lives we bring entertainment to
their lives and during covid they turn
to us for everything
so I don't think that your assumption
that they don't really care about
anything but being entertained over the
summer is the bottom line when the
people that give so much to them and
enrich their lives in so many ways are
saying
we are being taken advantage of in a
terrible way and if we let this happen
to US dollars for donuts it's going to
happen to you and your family your
children and everybody that you work
with too that's how threatening this
moment is in our nation's history
for us
all right still photos please
[Music]
yeah
I think we should make a fifth something
now that we're
we're doing our normal race
so photographers
still photographers
finishes
yes
[Music]
25.
foreign
[Applause]
yes
please
thank you
foreign